hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to neverending
nightmares there is a lot of creepy crap
going on in the distance and I am very
eager to fight find out what the hell is
going on I'm still a little sick I just
picked this up immediately from my last
play what is that that tape recorder
no it's an ass ready ok so the noise
palette has definitely changed from the
last episode that still got that awesome
picture going on here but methinks
there's going to be a great increase in
the number of spiders in this particular
never-ending nightmare
hello taker tonker sailor soldiers how
are you doing good oh god somehow they
made the dolls creepier than they were
before this is good Oh
okay why are you didn't want to look at
that I could have gone my whole life
without looking at that why did I want
away why stop that stop that go away No
okay so anyway I can do without the
moaning I think I mentioned that in the
last episode I'm generally a no moan guy
okay anyway continuing on oh good the
hallway of darkness and nightmares
exactly what I want at least the
wallpaper here isn't just pure skulls
you know something tells me that doesn't
lead to Narnia I have a good feeling
that leads to none egg nerd all cackling
running why not oh I'm hiding oh it's
like am bees all over again ooh where
did I go where did I go I don't think I
wanna know
this is where I have no idea what else
happens in the game so I'm like actually
on edge to see what's going on there are
way too many of those eyeless dolls
that's just generally not okay I'm list
of things that I would put up with I'm
very low on my list high low know that I
would not put up anyway I don't like I
am NOT doing okay cuz crying from the
basement
very good once again let's go down I
don't have my candle this time so I
don't know what's gonna happen it's
getting louder isn't it oh okay alright
okay
oh good it's locked up in here and even
more dolls my favorite I don't know what
I'm doing I don't want to know what I'm
doing
woah it's you wait a minute wait I mean
haven't I been here before
whoa hold on a second I heard something
sorry
my nose running a little bit still sick
but I'm hearing things that are standing
out from the normal pallet of nightmares
hello what is that that fat what is that
that's different that wasn't there
before let's find out what it is I don't
like you shut up I'm not Thomas that's
my brother you want to get with my
brother go talk to him
Sousa I think there's no point to these
rooms that I go in they just have
nothing in them and I don't much
appreciate the fact that there's nothing
in there for me I just tried it to the
end of this so that I can have a happy
lovely day there's just more dolls why
is that baby crawling out of a sewing
machine
there's mannequins in here too
what is the point of this where am I
going
oh you look cheerful oh man my throat's
nonde hai is that you screaming in the
distance is that just your magical box
I'm getting hot like I was running a
fever earlier so I'm at it it's coming
back a little bit and I'm sure that the
stress of playing this game is
exacerbated
I can barely talk
I can't even formulate words right now
but let's press on okay hello hi hello
Lindahl are you - oh good another one
with all the oh one with its entire face
missing haven't I been here before
does that one lead to narnia is anyone
gonna answer my questions
no are you kidding me are you kidding me
they're gonna get a long-arm baby over
here that's a long arm baby that's a big
baby with no okay I made a tour I'm in a
terrible error I'm gonna go this way
quickly
what the hell is I supposed to be oh
good lordy yeah you don't wants to see
you okay then well I was normal to some
big armed baby coming through
no I imagine that it's some amalgamation
like you know how all these dolls is
kind of glob together is one and then
hello hi well this was a look at all of
you was I supposed to stare at you until
anything happens or was I supposed to
bash her was I supposed to bash your
head up and take what was inside
cuz I didn't look at that one I have no
idea what a big big that big guy better
not be here to meet me cuz I would
really like to know what the hell is
going on
why baby cry hello well this is a happy
I know happy whoa that one I can't look
at so only the ones with flowers I can
look at but I don't know if there's a
point I have a bad feeling that I'm just
endlessly looping around for another big
arm baby bigger I'm baby big baby arm
big um baby baby the weird think about
the babies those holy silent was like no
chase music or anything it was this hey
there
I'm a biggest thing that's weird why
were there two things no yes No
okay have I been here before
oh hi hi there I don't know what you're
supposed to do hurry missed one like
yeah I get you yeah I got you don't
worry I got you oh I didn't even notice
that one trapped up in the cobwebs up
there oh you've heard that right you
heard that that's the stupid thing that
they're doing with the headphones when I
first loaded this up there was like this
thing that it said who are you sure
you're wearing headphones because we
have this special technology that can
make you really piss your pants and
it'll be hilarious cuz we're all
watching this I swear if their dick okay
I'm going down towards where the babies
are crying that's usually a bad thing in
organs or I'm just gonna be on another
level where there's more things okay
seriously what is the point what is the
point of all this what is the point is
there anything in these rooms that I
need is there anything anywhere that I
need I don't know I don't know all I
know is that I'm probably making a
horrible mistake
what are these poor characters what is
that about weight is a big arm baby
coming gonna come Bastian through there
I have a feeling like that's the thing
that might happen this does like that
happened it's exactly what happened oh
hi there friend I've in trouble barn hi
open whoa
whoa okay then okay didn't know if he
was gonna come barging through or not
what the hell oh where am I now
well whoa whoa there's one of you
staring deep into the darkness over here
I see Oh God my throat is going all my
voice isn't ruined for the livestream
but oh I get it I need to be careful
about what where I'm walking you got
four oh come on
oh those bedrooms are checkpoints I get
it aah or is it not did I just make a
terrible mistake I made a terrible
mistake
oh no maybe I didn't stop panicking so
much the only creepy eyeless dolls
everywhere you go staring I do notice
something the dolls aren't staring at
the person the dolls are staring at me
or more specifically at you now why
would they be doing that you're oh no no
no no no I said no oh you're not gonna
do it again huh
fine something's moving in the darkness
there
well can you guys see that something's
moving I know you guys can't see where
I'm pointing but things are moon now
this game is just unnerving this is like
what what is everything wise that's a
big guy in it it's a big guy ain't it
oh there's a big guy is it is it is deep
you can't give me yeah how's it going
friend oh man you're so vascular oh
you've been working out one arm in
particular oh come on how is that even
fair but this guy not see me when I go
behind him I'm pretty sure that I need
to sneak up behind him and get in this
wardrobe here yeah yeah yeah yeah ain't
nothing ain't no thing hook hello sorry
Melissa again with the baby crying the
crying babies could do without that
could do without them
come on lumpy hey Fung be thump over
this way
that's right that's right big guy come
on no no no no no one's making fun of
your loincloth come on no no oh you son
of a [ __ ] I like the way your belly
jiggles is your move by going this way I
don't know if I made a mistake or oh
there's another thing over there that
would have been useful well wait a
minute why are you doing that well don't
tell me there's another one there cannot
be another one hot pepper thought I
heard one
well is it well those aren't good son
aha ah I knew it I know you're one of
these douchebags well come here I want
to scratch your bumbum I'm gonna stretch
scratchy a bum bum hole fat huh Oh is he
leaving me okay
listen oh oh did that just scramble me
into bits oh no I'm good I'm good good
bye ain't no thing
ain't no thing I'm tough I'm a tough guy
where am I going now wait a minute the
last time that I climbed the stairs I
saw my sister hanging herself or someone
had to hang her hung her hanged her nope
nope even worse got a lot of dolls oh
this is the other end of the place that
I was good yeah that is really creepy to
notice that all the dolls are only
staring at the camera for the most part
hi is where you were stabbed I guess no
don't no don't pull it out that's like
okay that's a logical decision why would
you do that
oh and things get interesting
okay so
okay so we got a new sound palette going
on now and that is really interesting
the next time I pick this up I will not
be incredibly sick so hopefully you guys
have been enjoying this so far someone
in my padded cell here my lovely pet so
anyway I hope you guys are really
enjoying this one this is getting very
very interesting for me but oddly enough
I think this game deserves a little more
respect when I'm not sick so I'm gonna
pick it up later I really hope you guys
are enjoying this let me know what you
think of this game in the comments below
I really want to know who you think
about this game because I really really
like this game I love the way it like
brings you it like the monster they're
not threatening at all like not even a
little bit scary Domino's not even a
little bit scary he's really cool though
but the item can it could be done to
look better but the game itself the
world really creepy and interesting I
want to know more about it so either way
thank you all so much for watching check
out other Let's Plays I've done in the
description below or in the annotations
over there
and thanks again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye thanks Pierre is that to stand
trails of the ball another face
Oh
you